one of the things that I spent a lot of
time talking about on my channel and
even in my book is intersexual
relationships uh you've been married for
a long time
um what would you
is there any one thing are there things
that you would identify as success
mechanisms that has allowed that to work
out for you
um another actually let me ask you this
question first when you hear the sound
bite happy wife happy life what comes to
mind first of all
oh it's stupid it's the dumbest thing in
the world it's the I'll tell you why
it's the dumbest thing in the world
other people's happiness does not make
you happy like everybody else's
happiness is their responsibility and
your responsibility is to be happy like
it doesn't get easier
oh just just through the the the
auditing of The Narrative of the stories
in my head you know it's just like
realizing that people respond to
different things that were completely
different than mine that had nothing to
do with the actual facts or
circumstances it had to do with their
personal reality inside of their brain
their hallucinations about how the
world's supposed to be so it's like the
more you unpack that you realize like oh
other people's happiness include dude I
tell my kids daily your emotional health
is not my responsibility I'm here to
support you I'm here to work with you
but you are responsible for your mental
health like that's how much I believe
that my job you know my life isn't going
to be dependent on and like if my kids
are entrepreneurs or complete failures
it does not personally it's not gonna be
a reflection on me as a father I knew I
showed up and I did the work and my
intentions were there and the activities
were there how somebody else responds to
that that's on them and I think the
moment you can disconnect that you live
a completely different life where my
wife's happiness is not not gonna it
doesn't make me happy now do I want to
become the person who can support people
around me in their Journey hell yeah man
like this is this is the part where
you know I shared this recently where my
dad you know we've always had like a
really cool relationship I went through
chaos and hell with him as a teenager
and then he actually moved parts of town
for me to to get sober and stay sober
and he bought all these computer books
for me and he's just he's my hero but
there's always like this awkwardness
like he it's like he never and for all
the boys you know to to other brothers
he never did any one-on-one stuff which
sounds crazy to some people but we just
thought it was normal and about a year
and a half ago he finally said yes to
come and spend time one-on-one with just
me for two days and and then in that
moment time together I would ask him you
know do you want to work out do you want
to come in oh no no I don't want to slow
you down blah blah and then I got a
major snow biking accident with Brad I
fell off a 25-foot cliff and took my
handlebars and my my femur and so I was
injured so I asked my dad do you want to
come to the gym we were in Nashville at
one of my events he came to and he goes
okay Young Buck since you're injured you
know
and my dad worked out with me every day
for four days in a row every morning and
that was the first time I'm 43 dude he
said no to me for 20 years
and I share this because I wanted to if
I didn't become the person who could
show up and be consistent and create the
space and be willing to ask and never
turn that off I would have never been at
a place where now he said yes and I just
think like other people's happiness is
their responsibility but in the same
breath my responsibility is to become
the best version of myself so I am
prepared to support them when they're
ready for me like my my family my mom
still struggles with different things
and I feel like my whole family has
written my mom off she's seven years old
and they've written her off she sleeps
with a sleep apnea machine she's very
unhealthy she can't walk upstairs and I
still hold the belief that she could
absolutely transform her life
and until she takes her last breath
there will never be a moment of belief
where I don't believe that
because I just know I've seen it happen
thousands of times for people doesn't
matter what stage of their life young or
old in a moment things can absolutely
change and you can see miracles happen
but if I'm not in a position when she's
ready to make that decision to support
her because I didn't do the work then
that I think would be the biggest
fallacy so it's not my responsibility if
my wife's happy but it's my
responsibility to become the person that
does the work the trauma the the you
know all that stuff that have the
financial resources do we have a family
coach we fly her in from California to
come live with us and look at how we
interact and give us feedback that's not
inexpensive I get it's a luxury but I
also realize that's why I get up and do
what I do is so that whatever I need if
if I get a call to my kids sick and
there's a two million dollar operation
that is done in Guatemala
and I can't pay for that I don't want to
I don't wanna I can't even imagine what
that would feel like what is the uh
there's a family coach what does a
family coach do like what was the big
aha moment for you with that oh there's
so much I mean think about this Rich
there's the story you tell people that
happen and then there's what really
happened so so having her live wake up
in the morning watch us interact see the
moment see that this take us
individually do some one-on-one take the
boys one-on-one ask them questions probe
integrate those learnings come to dinner
with us like the whole shebang
um was just really valuable the biggest
one I'll share with people that it
sounds subtle but really changed the way
like literally on a daily basis we
change our Behavior was called takeoffs
and landings meaning that when I leave I
used to just go it's like this morning I
had a uh run with my buddy rich in the
past I would just leave I would just go
at seven in the morning I'm meeting my
buddy I'm gonna go for right I'll come
home now because of learning this when I
go to leave I go find my wife I give her
a big hug I tell her I love you babes
I'm heading out for a run with Rich I'll
be back at eight that subtle thing means
so much to her and to me when I come
home it feels great because there's a
landing that everybody goes hey what did
you do how are you doing right versus
just staying busy doing their thing I
mean it sounds so subtle but it's like
these little tweaks that can have such a
beautiful impact
um and that's just the small stuff she
did so much other things as well but
we've been working with her for like
five years I mean and I have an
emotional coach for my kids I mean I'm
just a big fan of investing in the
world's best to teach us the skills that
I think are Force multipliers for huge
impact on our lives I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out